one of my favorite things about Demon
Slayer is how the monk Gaga portrays
surveillance it is clear that there's a
fundamental thesis being put forth by
the author demons aren't born evil often
they're difficult and unfair lives that
were filled with suffering turned them
into the monsters they would eventually
become you can say that this is the case
for demons like cure guy and Louie they
were dealt a bad hand to begin with and
mix that with the misfortune that
follows turning into a demon and you get
a sort of monster cocktail and even then
both are monsters who in the end show
glimpses of humanity showing that that
humanity was inside of them all along it
was just repressed due to difficult life
circumstances shown in series in general
are good at portraying villains in an
empathetic way they show us how they
become the way they are and furthermore
that it is possible for them to change
even if that change happens in their
last moments just think about how Vegeta
changed in Dragon Ball Z think about how
God a change in Naruto a goddess stands
out to me as one of the best examples of
the villain to hero journey he is the
perfect character foil for Naruto he had
it even worse than Naruto growing up
rather than being saved by someone like
lucas insane the only person gada
trusted his uncle yashamaru told him he
hated him and that he would never be
loved by anyone before he tried to kill
him on gaara's father's orders
Gaara not surprisingly became the
monster everyone expected him to be
deprived of any love and companionship
he became a selfish monster
however Naruto understanding where he
was coming from and how he could have
ended up the same way if circumstances
were different helps Gaara overcome his
tragic past
then Gaara goes on to become the leader
of his village before Naruto even
succeeds in becoming the leader of the
hidden leaf village and Gaara genuinely
becomes one of the nicest and most
selfless guys in the series I'd say that
Icaza the third demon moon is up there
with Gaara as being one of the best
written villains in anime and in order
to illustrate this I will be looking at
manga spoilers so you've been warned if
you don't want to hear any manga
spoilers click off the video right now
anyways like Gaara
ah cuz I didn't just freely choose to be
a
villain he just adapted to the
circumstances around him because he had
to in order to survive the first thing a
casa does in the series is Kilrain Goku
the flame pillar although he would have
preferred if wearing Goku turned into a
demon Rango who refused so he ended up
dying from the wounds that are cos I
gave him at this point ran Goku was a
very likeable character not only was he
overpowered which helps us like
characters he was also an amazing person
he is completely calm as he's dying
he tells ton j'adore not to worry about
him dying and that it is natural for a
pillar to become the shield of his
juniors his last spoken words were that
he truly believes in tundra and his
friends then he dies was a smile on his
face for as much as we have come to like
it and Goku up to this point we have
come to hate Icaza because he killed
such an amazing person and then fled
like a coward before the Sun came up or
dislike for Icaza only grows as we go on
to see how the death of Ren Goku goes on
to affect rain Goku's family time zero
and the other demon hunters by the time
Icaza shows up again and calls tangent
our weakling before going on to fight
him and give you it's safe to say that
the reader has been trained not to like
him he's one of the bad guys he killed a
good likable person he insults and wants
to kill our lovable protagonist and so
on and yet after this battle I
thoroughly empathize with akasa and
don't actually hold on to any dislike
for him not only that but he goes on to
become one of my favorite villains in
all of anime how is this complete 180
turn around possible well let's take a
closer look at how the mangaka
skillfully manages to pull this off by
using some top-tier writing witchcraft
the key to changing our perception about
Icaza lies in his backstory behind every
great villain there's a Great backstory
which somehow explains their actions
once again the arto comes to mind Gaara
had one as did Madara as did pain no
matter how bad their actions seemed at
first after we find out their backstory
and motivations we can start to see how
they could come to the conclusion that
they came to as the battle between akka
Santangelo and EU is approaching its
conclusion a ghost girl appears before
our Kazaa at this point on 0 is out cold
and he was so tired and
injured that it's a miracle he can still
fight at all a demon who as Q points out
has no concept of fatigue or injury is
the clear favorite to win at this point
and yet when victory is all but assured
this ghost girl shows up telling Alcazar
to let go cuz it doesn't recognize her
but she tells him to come to the other
side
aka join her in the afterlife akiza says
he can since he has to kill people he
has to become stronger he has to kill
anyone who gets in his way the girl asks
why he wants to be stronger and he
answers because he won't be able to
bring it back if he doesn't get stronger
the it he is referring to is medicine
for his father and that cused the
flashback which has given a lot of space
in the manga entire chapters are devoted
to it thus from the sheer amount of
space given to the backstory it is clear
that the manga is serious about
developing this character so back to the
medicine Oscar says dad was sick and
need an expensive medicine his mother is
not in the picture all aqua has is his
sick dad so akka is a being the caring
son he was decided that he would acquire
the funds to pay for the medicine by any
means necessary he wants to become
stronger so he can run away with stolen
wallets beat people who come back for
revenge and escape from the magistrate
and his beatings he eventually gets
caught three times for pickpocketing and
gets three pickpocketing tattoos on his
arm
not only is he visibly branded as a
criminal for all to see at the age of
eleven he is warned the next time his
wrist will be cut off think about what
you were doing at 11 years old my
biggest problem was probably forgetting
to save Pokemon crystal on my gameboy
color
akiza on the other hand is getting
beaten up and punished regularly he has
to provide for his parent rather than
the other way around then they
threatened to cut off his hands and
anybody who tried to play gameboy color
without using their hands knows that
your hands are very important odd cosa
isn't scared though he just laughs he
tells them to go ahead and cut them off
he'll still have his feet to use for
pickpocketing he does not feel guilty or
ashamed of his behavior at all and why
would he he's following his moral
compass from his perspective he's doing
the right thing his father's medicine is
too expensive for him to get the money
through any legal means he's doing
whatever he can do to save his dad
it just so happens that the only way to
save has that in this unfair world is to
break the law they give an
eleven-year-old Icaza 100 blows that
would even make a large-sized man go
numb they're shocked that a kid could
take so much damage and they call him a
demon child but he's not a demon he just
has a really strong purpose in life that
drives him in other words he is a
powerful why in his life to take care of
his dad and as Nietzsche said he who has
a why to live for can bear almost anyhow
Viktor Frankl adds that people who see
meaning in their lives are able to
transform a personal tragedy into a
triumph this is how kid Icaza is able to
smile after receiving a punishment that
would crush a large-sized man as oft as
i put it they may whip me and break my
bones but I can endure anything for you
dad even if it lasts hundreds of years
and quote he would gladly die for his
father can you imagine this kind of
selflessness and drive coming from an
eleven-year-old I don't know about you
but for me this is the furthest you can
get from being a villain and then after
everything he went through for his dad
his dad hangs himself the only person in
his life his reason for living is
suddenly gone all akka says left with is
his pain physical and emotional his
father left him a letter where he
explained that he wants his son to live
an honest life he wants our casa aka
Haku G to turn over a new leaf his
father didn't want to live off a
mined-out stolen from others his father
apologizes for being a nuisance he
killed himself because he thought it
would be the best thing for his son but
it's the absolute last thing that akasa
wanted a casa hugs his father's grave
and contemplates how unfair being poor
is and how unpaired the world and its
people are his father was never a bother
to him and never did anything wrong so
he wonders why he had to die off cuz I
starts taking out his frustrations on
the unfair people of the world and he
gets stronger he is able to defeat seven
adults with his bare fists when he meets
kaizo who runs a martial arts dojo where
he teaches a bare fisted fighting style
called saudi kaizo is a guy you can't
help but love he has this big smile on
his face as he approaches Icaza and
invites him to join his dojo
even though he can see from his tattoos
that he's a banished criminal from Edo
Arkansas tax kaizo and hazel whoops his
butt like clobbering his face with many
quick punches sensei kaizo doesn't even
break a sweat in the process so kaizo
ends up taking the aimless criminal
under his wing keep in mind that akiza
has nothing going for him at this point
except being strong he's got no purpose
anymore and he's a branded criminal
so most people want nothing to do with
him but hazel doesn't care
hazel has no students because of jealous
rival dojos so he has to make his daily
wages by doing some handyman work he has
a sick daughter and he has no one to
watch her while he's away since his wife
killed herself she couldn't handle the
toll that taking care of a sick daughter
who never seemed to get better took on
her despite the fact that he's been
labeled a criminal kaizo trusts akasa to
watch over his daughter the single most
important thing in his life
hazel is one of the first people who
doesn't treat a Kazaa like a criminal
and that's all aqus I was looking for
now that someone sees the value in him
he's more than happy to live up to that
person's expectations
I guess Amit's casos daughter who is
called koyuki in her he sees a second
chance to make up for the fact that he
couldn't save his sick father he gladly
commits himself 100% to heal and koyuki
and he doesn't need any convincing in
fact it bothers him how sick people
always apologize he knows that they
would do things for themselves if they
could they apologize for coughing but
it's not their fault they want to
breathe normally sick people are in the
most pain so our casa really does
understand why they keep apologizing
this is how nice of a guy a casa is he
never once complains about helping
koyuki
or missing out on other things he wants
to be with her and to help her as he
explains quote koyuki had a really weak
body she had to be attended on
throughout the night and I had to change
both the cloth and her forehead and her
clothes she had to drink water
frequently and whenever she went to the
bathroom I had to carry her and quote
evidently it's a lot of work and yet our
Castle doesn't find it hard at all he
never thought of going to play and he
doesn't want to see fireworks until
koyuki is healthy enough so that they
can see them together not
only those Arkansas want to contribute
he even says that training in the dojo
and nursing koyuki saved his heart he
spends three years like this training
and nursing eventually his nursing pays
off and koyuki stops lying down all the
time she starts to be able to live
normally
then one day Kay's will sit sokka's a
down he wants to give a casada dojo and
his daughter's hand in marriage
even though he's a branded criminal
Octus I never imagined he would be loved
by someone or even have a future Akasa
finally sees that it might be possible
for him to follow his father's dying
wish it might be possible for him to
live the right way he finally lets
himself hope for a better life he would
give anything to protect kaizo and
koyuki he is so grateful for everything
they did for him that's when it happens
because it goes to his father's grades
and tell him about his upcoming marriage
when he comes back to the dojo he finds
out that the jealous rival dojo has
poisoned their well because they
couldn't beat kaizo or Icaza in a fair
fight both kaizo and koyuki are dead
after a tragic life of struggle and pain
Akasa had finally gotten to a good place
he finally let his guard down and
allowed himself to hope for a good
future and then it was all taken away
from him in a moment he blames himself
for not being able to live up to his
promise he had promised a koyuki that he
would become stronger than anyone else
and protect her for his entire life
however just like with his dad he
couldn't save her and his promise was
nothing but words knowing his story I
don't think you can blame Akasa for
wanting revenge against the rival dojo
except beating them up is not enough for
him he goes in murder 67 swordsmen with
his bare hands the story seemed so
absurd that was regarded as a fictitious
tale for thirty years before it was a
race from the record after he gets his
revenge he is walking around aimlessly
again he has lost his reason for living
again he has no why he has nothing to
protect anymore this is when he runs
into Musa who has heard that there's a
demon in the area but it's really just a
Caza Mouzon goes on to turn akasa into a
demon and he loses his memories he wants
strength once again even though there's
nothing
left for him to protect he didn't want
to live anymore but moves on turned him
into a demon who would go on to murder
people pointlessly for over a hundred
years so that's the back story of a casa
interestingly enough even though he lost
his memories he was the only demon who
refused to kill or eat women even as a
brainwashed demon he still continued to
hold on to some principles that he
wouldn't break now let's go back to the
fight it was heading towards a
conclusion but koi Yuki's ghost helps
our Casas realize that there is no
longer a reason for him to keep fighting
his goal was to get stronger so he could
protect his loved ones but his loved
ones are long dead and he would have
been dead by now too if he didn't turn
into a demon thus he has no more reasons
to fight he has no more reasons to get
stronger ton zero wakes up and starts
rushing towards a casa but has no
strength in his hand so he drops the
sword it seems like it's over but Akasa
realizes that this whole time when he
was killing others he was actually
trying to kill himself
he smiles at Angira then he self
destructs in a way where he wouldn't
hurt the demon hunters he decides to go
to hell gracefully and in between this
world and the next he sees his father
son say and lover again he apologizes
for what he became but they all still
love him they haven't forsaken him even
if they can't take him to heaven koyuki
once again gives him permission to let
go Naza cries in her arms and she
welcomes her love home he himself says
his home before he and koyuki are
consumed by the flames of hell what a
field trip I can't remember the last
time a character story affected me as
much as a cos øz did he truly is a
product of an unfair world yet even in
an unfair world he never fully let go of
his humanity and in the end he turned
back into his old self he tried to save
his father's life and he was punished
for it then his dad killed himself
then after hitting rock bottom he
decided to give life on the other chance
he completely dedicated himself to
helping kaizo and koyuki things started
looking good he started to really
believe that he could live a good life
and for the second time it was all
snatched away from him
he took revenge on the people who
snatched it all from him and then moves
on found him
he no longer cared about anything he
brainwashed him and turned him into a
demon yet even though he lost his
memories he still refused to eat or kill
women he still held on to some moral
principles he was so strong that he
couldn't even be beaten by our main
characters he had to choose to die he
died on his own terms while he could
have potentially went on and killed GU
Anton judo yes he killed rain Goku
but the whole time he was hoping not to
kill him he was trying to turn him into
a demon and at the time Octus I didn't
think that was a bad thing in the end he
was an accidental villain he was turned
into a villain by the circumstances of
his life by the cruel world and when he
regained his memories he defeated
himself and gracefully went to hell if
he wasn't forced to become a criminal to
save his father
and if his loved ones weren't poisoned
he would have lived the right kind of
life like his father wanted him to for
all these reasons I amplified with a
kazoo he did horrible things especially
as a demon so he has to atone for those
sins however you can see how he got
there the manga shows us how even a
selfless caring person can become a
monster under the right or should I say
wrong conditions and it's completely
believable I think our cuz those loved
ones were right not to forsake him yes
he made big mistakes but Icaza isn't a
bad guy at heart
in fact his whole story illustrates how
even good people can be made to do
really bad things this is why fiction
like demon slayer is important it makes
us more empathetic it helps us realize
that we don't always know what people
are going through we can't judge a book
by its cover and we shouldn't assume
that someone's a terrible person because
they have pickpocketing tattoos and as
we become more empathetic we realize
that we all have to do our part to make
this world a better place so that there
will be less cruelty in the world and in
turn less monsters born from that
cruelty and that is it for today's video
thank you so much for watching let me
know who your absolute favorite villain
and anime is and why in the comments if
you enjoyed this video make sure to
smash that like button to let me know if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
ring that notification bell so you
actually get notified when new videos
drop for more content including crucial
anime updates follow us on Instagram and
at Anime uproar a big thank you goes out
to our patrons on patreon who help make
videos like this one possible I
especially want to thank our pro hero to
your patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings
August angel Cruz Steelers and Pablo
Pablo and are the one tier patrons the
ones who stay atop all clans baby ray a
seventeen ffvp Steven Ingrid ah a Lola
autumn Mattie Mac 239 makoto-kun keelon
and elrico dames and the Patriots who
transcend greatness itself Regan
Harrison and Lord Noxon or the chosen
few who have been acknowledged by Lord
we go himself if you enjoy our work you
can support more of it by going over to
patreon calm animals roar and becoming a
patron today for as little as $1 if you
do so you'll get your name featured in
future videos alongside these amazing
people right here and you'll even get
access to our private patient only
discord
so check out patreon.com/lenguin
if you're interested and until next time
see you space cowboy
[Music]